ua
よしが oc 位これじゃあ肇社長です準備今日まで僕はねあれでしょ色々あって大切
な大変だったんですけど自分が張ってねこの重い体をね頑張って学校に行ってきました
競歩スーツですじゃあこのあこの束ねた俺いや
にはやっぱりなペットしかないんだよペットこんなこちらですどうぞ
麺屋八なメイドインちゃんやってくれてる大丈夫か別に中国を辞するわけじゃないけど
やっぱ中国産なるとちょっとアレですよね
ちょっといいんですけどこれを今日はねあげていこうと思いますはずめ開封後
これ毎回思うんだけど意味ないんですよね結局2なければいいんだけどねあーもーこぼ
こになっちゃっや今回はまずすごいですよ出でよ新しいあるのペット
グレアですこういう教令が入ってるんですけどもねまって日本を変えてなくに終わった
あじゃあ俺英語読めるんだ米を呼べるんだ妻を亡くしたカードプレイヤーンっていう
恐竜がですねちょっと今までのペットとひと味違うよあっちな方の生き物でキロボて
ませんロボットを超えたロボットって書いてあったからもうずべくをいただきましょう
ちょっと日本が書いてないからちょっときついわ
前回買ったね犬のロボットはね実家に起きました
今から俺のじいちゃんと遊んでますでも向いているずっと良かったこちら日本語だから
選んでいきましょう
まず取り出すアンパークプレーを箱がれており打席は片手
片方の手はお腹の下にそんなルールなどピョン自分のゆっくりとした基本動作と浣腸
責めされますこれは食べ物を欲しがりっ
歩きますね vale を探索するでしょうそして色々な館長はだまっちさんはじめ
ます
決まった動きをするわけじゃないらしっててがちなも生き物敵ロボクラセルサイズ
プレーを出してみましょう
これがガイドだ
うわぁ競って帰って会ちょっとでかいん
冬はなんかだけ黒い
これはこれ10年間もう入ってないことになります
うわちょっと臭い無駄に皮膚感なリアルな気持ち悪い
充電は例えば10年じゃあ充電器の端ないぞ
て待って待って待って待った10バッテリーない風で入ってないんだけど
バッテリーないよバッテリー別売りとか箱の中に全部入ってねープレイをでしょ
ピザとガイド酒歯 yuta 使いでこれでしょ
充電器これかのいやいやいやいやえ待ってが地内はない入ってないんだけどちょっと
待ったいやっ入っていうのは雨読投げたっけやだけてないそうね待ってあって小澤
マリア
なんか無駄に覚え恐竜の人形を買っただけど辛いで何カチッパッテリーがないんです
ねっ
待って歯を抜かれてたということで待って待って待ってちょっと待って
どこに問い合わせればいいってうわしまずはこれは問題だよ
あ橋南現地まってなんかバッテリーと充電スタンドは別の日に来るらしいです
もう危険のかもちょっと見てくる
レーザーレーダー
別で電池が届きましたこれはねちょっとで巧妙なテクニックだねだって完全遺産を国庫
に誰チューブ熱入るような場所があったので別で立地お姉ちゃん送ってくるとちょっと
してあれが入りはせいかなにかかなぁちょっとわからないんだけど完全にベッドでき
ました
完全にこれでパイプレイヤーのデンツですやあやあやっと動く
マジで
は本当にとりあえず充電しますやっとがぱねぇはようやくですよ
予約愛しのペットと再会に会う日やおまけでしたね
はじめにアイターいって言ってるじゃあそれを張ってに入れます行くよ
フライ打ち込むどうすればいいだろう
前面の付け方とか何をわかんないんだよオーナー動けるかん
ふーっ
おはようあ
ああああああ
南雲のずっとこう
オゴオゴ末信なおい
なんだこれ言うかなぁ
ランドズームっ
う
全然動かないじゃん
起きて起きたを
思う
ああああああああ
こんにちはう
なんか今日で起きないんだよなお前どうスター
まあこれくらい戦車なんかあさんだからでパパですね
バカだからバカバカ早く起きて未だ本当に生まれたばったりだから10分間くらいで
起きたいうらしいです
歌った立てるようになったのかバター
ああああ米500だよ
沖田っぽいしてねどうやら名前元気そうで何よりであったろう
ん
調理器ですかお前そっちは危ないからこっち行く時
いいいいい
よほら等の家ではバトルしてそれは攻撃な
どうせどうせ
なってこのことはしたくないんですよ
午後
ちょっと可愛く見えてきた自分がいるよ早くないんだなぁん午後
を事5号的なぜひくれよなぁかへとは言いませんがのほほんとしまったらカメラ産地や
ざあなは
me
ません
ん